when things get tough for him this is  true story Donald Jr has a special place  to go where he can hit the pause button  sit and reflect we've actually captured  these moments of reflection in something  we call Trump on a stump it really  goofed up this time Donny now dad will  never stop calling me Tiffani and this  mess is all over I'll show them all I'm  gonna run for president of jail dad  keeps calling this a witch hunt man that  sounds fun how come I've never gone on a  witch hunt I bet I could bring a witch  down with one shot if someone held her  really still I don't care if everyone  calls me Fredo because he was the best  character in Lord of the Rings the worst  part of all of this I voted for Hillary  [Applause]  you